se você já reparou na imensa diversidade
que existe ao seu redor sob o mesmo céu
que você vivem com vivem e sobrevivem
pessoas os mais diversos credos crenças
orientações sexuais políticas e
ideológicas essa diversidade ela é muito
interessante da gente tem mente quando a
gente está circulando uma só vez a gente
não preste muita atenção e por que que
eu acho que ter esse monte de gente
diferente que viveu conviveu o
sobreviveu a desafios diferentes da
gente é importante de ter na nossa
convivência a gente tem um limite eu
diria técnico da nossa imaginação a
gente acha que pode imaginar diferentes
cenários diferentes desafios mas a
verdade é que a gente tem um limite
pessoal do como a gente consegue fazer
essas imaginações não é uma questão de
falta de esforço minha ou sua não é que
a gente não tá tentando é que realmente
difícil a gente falar sobre uma
experiência que a gente não viveu um
fato que a gente não conheceu uma
situação que a gente não sobreviveu Ou
pelo menos que não conviveu com eu
acredito que esses os nossos pessoais de
imaginação de convivências de
experiências eles são hoje um dos
gargalos da tecnologia a gente tem
tecnologia estão tendo problemas que
estão cometendo erros ou que não estão
sendo tão inclusivas como deveriam
porque a nossa imaginação é mais
fechadinha como se a gente tivesse vendo
o mundo por um funil e para sair desse
funil a gente precisa ter outras pessoas
nos ajudando até essa visão de mundo e
se essa convicção que eu tenho hoje que
são gargalo para inovação tecnológica é
recente a sensação de limite pessoal não
é eu conheci o meu limite pessoal pela
primeira vez que eu não comecei a
reparar nos outros lugares onde eu
andava eu sou natural da cidade de São
José dos Campos no interior de São Paulo
há cerca de 90 Km da capital paulista E
aqui onde vivências de certa forma um
pouco homogêneas eu tava em escolas onde
os meus colegas tinham vivências
semelhantes as minhas onde os
professores vinham de grupos sociais
semelhantes aos meus e aquilo tudo tinha
uma mesma bagagem vamos assim a e eram
semelhantes e quando eu sair da minha
cidade para estudar eu tinha cerca de
vinte e poucos anos eu fui para uma
outra cidade onde tinha minha
universidade e lá eu descobri o tamanho
da bolha que eu tava vivendo porque foi
lá que eu comecei a conversar conhecer
pessoas que não estavam naquele lugar
intermediadas por não sei a capacidade
de pagar a mesma mensalidade de escola
ou porque tinham um Patch no mesmo grupo
social ali as políticas afirmativas que
existiam na época trazia um pessoas dos
mais diferentes estados as mais
diferentes visões de mundo das mais
diferentes orientações pessoais
ideológicas tá conversar e aquele
enriquecer os ambientes das aulas mais
do que aprender eu aprendi a discutir
com pessoas que tinham visões diferentes
isso foi muito enriquecedor inclusive
que foi nessa época que eu tive a minha
primeira convivência com membros da
comunidade LGBT Key mais que eram
assumidamente membro daquela comunidade
e eu pude entender Que boa parte dos
preconceitos que eu trazia comigo
tinham-se se você tem esse nada para mim
e eu não tinha tido convivência se
pudessem desconstruir aqueles
preconceitos EA partir dessas vivências
diferentes nesse ambiente Universitário
eu fui entendendo a melhor forma de
interagir como respeitar como entender
que o que me diziam um refletir na
realidade essas conversas tanto de
convivência cisternas em ambientes
comuns quanto dentro das salas de aula
transformavam as conversas e mais
complexas Só que também me trazer um
melhores entendimentos eu não podia
entrar só com a minha visão de mundo eu
precisava entender e completar aquela
situação com outras visões com outras
percepções Isso foi me mostrando a
capacidade de enriquecimento de soluções
diante de problemas complexas
o pai não sabe que eu também tio
conceito de mérito ficou um pouco
complicado para mim como é que eu
poderia dizer que você pode se esforçar
para chegar lá sendo que muitas pessoas
que estavam ali comigo tinham feito as
forças enormes e sem políticas
afirmativas os incentivos institucionais
elas não teriam a chance detalhe comigo
e mais do que beneficiar aquelas pessoas
aquelas políticas que incluíam
diversidade no ambiente Universitário
elas beneficiavam mim também aquelas
conversas estão se tornando mais
complexas mais interessantes mais
relevantes para minha vida porque
aquelas pessoas tinham sido trazidas
para que eles ambientes E aí fica essa
questão como é que a gente garantir a
diversidade esse tema voltou de novo
quando eu já tava trabalhando como
jornalista de tecnologia E cobrindo
assistindo SW um evento de tendências e
inovação que acontece em Austin no Texas
E lá eu lembro de ter ouvido pela
primeira vez um desenvolvedor falando
sobre o desafio que é fazer um
desenvolvimento de software ético e
responsável o desenvolvedor chamava Reis
Ramos ele era mexicano me fala um pouco
sobre o desafio de saber que
Tecnicamente ele conseguiria ajudar a
resolver uma questão que era lidar com
os problemas estruturais causados nos
prédios na região doméstica e depois de
um terremoto em 2017 no mês de setembro
houve um terremoto bastante
significativo Em décadas naquele país e
o resolvi o seu time falar assim a gente
pode ajudar a gente pode criar um
aplicativo que reconhece essas imagens
das trincas nas casas e pode dizer se
essa trinca um problema estrutural e a
pessoa precisa sair daquela casa que
aquela casa pode desabar ou se não é um
problema estrutural ela pode
simplesmente consertar que ela trinca
mas só porque eu resolvi tinha se
comprometido em fazer um time de verso e
ético suficiente que envolveu não só
matemáticos em desenvolvedores mas
também filósofos e Engenheiros eles
pararam para pensar em outros quesitos
relacionados aquele desenvolvimento quer
dizer mais do que o intuito Nobre de
ajudar eles precisavam pensar na
responsabilidade que aquele aplicativo
ia ter um falso negativo por exemplo que
dissesse que aquela casa e não está com
problema estrutural mas ela estivesse
com aquele problema ia deixar uma
família dentro de um prédio que pode
desabar da mesma maneira um falso
positivo que fala esse prédio está
comprometido e vocês precisam sair e
Edis abrigar uma família e utilizar
recursos do governo por exemplo tá
auxiliar mas que ela desnecessários e
esse tipo de reflexão fez todo sentido
para você falar assim um time de verso
consegue fazer uma solução melhor da
mesma maneira adversidade recentemente
voltou à tona na discussão em relação à
tecnologia no documentário com o dedo
baias existe uma pesquisadora chamada
joia online do e matlab que descobriu
que as tecnologias de reconhecimento
facial e identificação das nossas faces
funcionavam muito melhor com faces de
pele clara e não eram tão eficiente
assim com pessoas de pele escura e ela
descobriu que esse problema até que não
gosta com essa falta de eficiência desse
algoritmo tinha a ver com um problema
literalmente de base das bases de dados
uma das não tinham sido colocadas
imagens de pessoas de pele escura para
que ela pudesse aprender com aquilo
então será que a diversidade de pessoas
no time não poderia ter lembrado que
você precisava de uma base de dados mais
robusta em termos de diversidade de
cores diferentes para garantir que
aquela tecnologia funciona assim melhor
e pensando sobre isso eu falei puxa vai
ser aqui só um problema pontual Será que
a gente tá falando que a diversidade é
uma coisa que acontece só em casa os
gringos internacionais eu comecei a
prestar atenção no meu próprio dia a dia
um dos primeiros momentos que eu percebi
a diferença que essa diversidade faz
aqui essas visões de mundo fazem
diferente na hora da tecnologia foi para
um colega jornalista de Moda Gustavo
torneira O Gustavo é deficiente visual
Ele não enxerga e ele para saber o que
por mais que a gente já tem a tecnologia
instrumentalizado ali é possível de usar
uma ferramenta para descrever imagens
para as pessoas que têm deficiência
visual baixa visão Muitas pessoas não
utilizam é aquela descrição que o sites
as mídias sociais tem que você falou que
tem naquela foto
e parece um vídeo um meme numa lista do
Twitter ou no noticiário Às vezes o
Gustavo não consegue acompanhar porque
ele não enxerga e ele criou um modelo
que eu achei muito interessante que é de
entrar na conversa e gentilmente falar
para as pessoas Viu vem cá você pode
descrever para mim o que está nesse
vídeo tá nas imagem e essa inclusão do
Gusttavo no setor de cobertura de
jornalismo de tecnologia ajuda a lembrar
que puxa a gente tem que lembrar de
descrever essas imagens e muitas vezes o
convite dele atendido e as pessoas
descrevem a imagem para ele e ele
agradece as pessoas ficam força lembrete
de que elas precisam dessa outra visão
de pessoas que vão se beneficiar com
alguma coisa que a gente pode influir
é da mesma forma um outro momento
recentemente eu fui convidado a divulgar
uma vaga de trabalho uma bolsa na
verdade para mestrandos e quando eu
comecei a divulgar Essa vaga ainda mais
considerando que a gente teve uma série
de cortes na investimento em ciência
recentemente essas bolsas são muito
raras e eu falei nossa vai ter muita
gente interessada e parte das pessoas
interessadas me chamava em privado me
chamava em separado para falar assim mas
já aqui essa bolsa precisa daquela prova
de inglês porque se precisar daquela
prova de inglês eu acho que eu não vou
conseguir competir e eu fui entender que
parte das bolsas de Mestrado estavam
pedindo uma certa certificação que as
pessoas até se disponham a fazer mas
elas não conseguiram atingir a pontuação
necessária para Aquela bolsa o que me
fez pensar que aquela bolsa continua
dessa primeiro tempo raramente Se
conseguiu colocar uma pessoa ali e eu
fiquei pensando se aqueles critérios
fazer um sentido se aquelas exigências
que estavam Associados com aquela a
bolsa realmente refletiu a realidade ou
se elas eram são reflexo que me o
ambiente Universitário elitizado Será
que precisava mesmo daquele nível de
pontuação para fazer as atividades
daquele bolsista e será que a gente
trouxesse esses bolsistas para perto
para conversar a gente não entenderia
que existiram outras formas a gente
falar puxa Será que a gente pode aliviar
um pouquinho em inglês e melhorar diante
das atividades do dia de ele é uma coisa
para você pensar e que você só consegue
trazer para perto quando você tem essas
pessoas para trazer essa nova visão e
você abre um espaço de conversa a
sensação que eu tenho é que no passado
foi um desconforto pessoal para mim hoje
vem à tona como políticas dsg como
questões que a gente tá colocando junto
com cuidado com o meio ambiente Impacto
social a governança das empresas mas
mais do que seguiu uma cláusula que os
investidores estão colocando para poder
colocaria nosso estampado investir na
sua empresa eu acho que a gente podia
pensar no porquê que a gente precisaria
investir nessa diversidade Qual é o
benefício que a gente tem e eu acredito
que o benefício é que a diversidade vai
se tornar uma chave para a gente
desenvolver as coisas é para ser
soluções magnéticas para ser soluções
que tem um impacto social mais benéfico
e positivo que incluam as pessoas dos
mais diferentes tipos que convivem com a
gente e que eu consigo lidar com os
problemas complexos os nossos problemas
a tecnologia não vão ficar mais fáceis
daqui por diante eles vão ficar mais
difíceis mas complexos mas amigos e se
eu tiver que falar para você prestar
atenção em uma dessas coisas que eu
comentei aqui agora eu tirei para
lembrar de uma coisa só que isso não é
culpa minha ou sua não questão da gente
achar quem é a pessoa a ser culpada por
esse problema mas entendi que essa é uma
oportunidade da gente abraçar essa
responsabilidade de mover o mundo para
um lugar melhor ao incluir pessoas
diversas se a gente pensar que vai ser
incluindo pessoas que não são
equivalentes da gente que a gente vai
ganhar novas visões quem sabe aquela
desafio gelada do comecinho posso
retornar um pouco mais amplo e
solucionar problemas de uma maneira
diferente se a gente dá espaço para
pessoas que têm lugar de fala que elas
possam colaborar com a gente a gente
pode trazer essas pessoas diversas com
visões de as conferências são diferentes
das nossas para nos ajudar a ultrapassar
os limites e lidar com as complexidades
que o mundo vem trazendo para ir se a
gente tiver a chance de juntos criar
Inovar certamente a gente vai conseguir
avançar muito obrigada